this video is brought to you by nordvpn
today we're asking the question can you
be too strong now your initial impulse
might be to say no that's a nonsense
question you can't be too strong just
like you can't be too happy or too
wealthy or too healthy however I think
that there are some circumstances and
contexts in which you certainly can be
too strong in fact it could be causing
you pain leading to injury and slowing
you down and making you a worse overall
athlete so that's how you get loads of
really strong people angry at you which
is not the smartest thing to do so
before you Lynch me let me explain
myself I'm not saying that you can't be
fast and strong or agile and strong in
fact I'm one of the first people to say
that you can I do not think that
building lots of muscle is going to slow
you down in fact I think it's going to
make you faster as long as you can tap
into that strength it's just that we
need to train our strength in relation
to other things and really answer the
question can you be too strong we need
to ask another question that being too
strong for what because I think you can
be too strong for your own good and the
first example of this that I can think
of is something that I had personal
experience with because if you're really
strong but you have poor technique and
you have poor Mobility perhaps you have
compensatory movement patterns then
actually that strength is opening up
more opportunities for injury so I went
through a phase where I stopped rock
climbing where I stopped doing martial
arts and all I did was a kind of
bodybuilding style training except I
didn't even really do legs properly yes
I went through that phase and on top of
this I was working at a desk nine to
five I was freelance but I still sat
down all day usually in coffee shops or
in my really small apartment with my
wife so I developed you know kyphosis
and I couldn't even squat deeply without
my heels coming up on the floor so I
wasn't moving great but I could still
lift an awful lot of weight I could
bench press double my body weight about
155 kilograms I could do like five reps
of 50 kilogram dumbbell presses things
like that and the problem is that I'm
now picking up those weights especially
those dumbbells but I don't have the
form or the posture to do this safely so
the very fact that I was strong enough
to lift the weight actually opened me up
to injury because I didn't have the good
movement patterns to back it up and of
course we see this all the time with
someone who can deadlift or someone who
can squat but they're not doing it
properly now if you're not very strong
you're not going to cause yourself that
much injury because you're not going to
use too much weight you might get the
movement wrong you might cause a little
bit of a tweak but it's not as bad as
squatting badly with 200 kilograms on
your back so here's a scenario where you
can be too strong you're too strong for
your own good and what you should do in
that scenario is ideally go back to the
drawing board you know stop the ego
lifts lighten your loads and focus on
your form and things like that first I
mean you do know you're a freak
you do not know what I know because you
have not earned those Powers you're
careless with those Powers you flaunt
them and you throw them around like a
brat with this trust fund
once again I'm the first to defend a
little bit of bad form I'm not a form
Nazi I don't think that every movement
has to be done perfectly in fact I think
a bit variation is good and I think
listening to your own body and the way
it moves is good however if you're
planning an awful lot of weight on then
you need to be really careful and move
properly so either lower the weight and
aim for a higher rep ranges perhaps and
stop when your body's telling you to or
go back to the drawing board and really
learn those movement patterns this is
where you can decide if you want to be
an all-rounder who moves in a variety of
ways or Specialists who learns those
specific movements really well but if
you're going to go that route then you
need to make sure you're doing it
properly interestingly I didn't have
that problem when I did martial arts or
rock climbing and this is one Avenue for
a more functional performance do your
power lifting do your bodybuilding or
whatever else but just add on top of
that some kind of activity that moves
the body dynamically in a similar vein
you can become too strong if your
muscles develop a lot but your tendons
can't keep up and this is an issue we
see a lot with steroid use not only
because this causes the muscles to get
stronger a lot faster but also because
the tendons they don't respond to
steroids in the same way so you're going
to get much bigger muscles and the
tendons are going to lag behind once
again this means you can lift the weight
but should you and if you end up going
to an extreme range of motion for
example you're going to injure yourself
or if you use a high rep range and the
tendon wears out
you want to know what your big mistake
was black what mistake it's that stolen
body
cells but you don't truly understand
because you didn't build it and you
never
alone
[Applause]
just as you need to think carefully
about how to ensure the best and
healthiest performance from your body
you also need to think carefully about
your Internet Security which brings me
to today's sponsor nordvpn so nordvpn is
a VPN that means a virtual private
Network and you can use this to relay
information via a server located
elsewhere and use this when browsing the
web to obfuscate your location it helps
to keep your information safer from
nefarious snoopers essentially by going
to the server the server looks up the
page and then it brings it back to you
so as far as anyone listening in is
concerned you're only connected to the
server they didn't know what goes on
beyond that point this also has other
uses for example it allows you to watch
content from other locations by
connecting to a server in that location
which then allows you to access Netflix
or another app as though you are from
that place plus notary fan offers a
bunch of other features for example
using their double VPN feature you can
actually set up a kind of chain of vpns
and thereby improving your Security even
further nordvpn is the fastest VPN
according to the latest speed tests it
works on a bunch of different devices
and I use it all the time you guys can
get access to an exclusive deal by
heading to nordvpn.com forward slash the
bioneer right now there's also a limited
offer getting you four months free if
you buy into their two-year plan
thanks again to nordvpn for sponsoring
this video and now on with the show
this is also an issue with myostatin
reduction whether you're talking about
future Gene modification techniques or
some of these supplements that claim to
lower myostatin myostatin actually plays
an important role in tendon repair and
maintenance so it goes beyond simply
muscles being too strong you're actually
actively reducing the strength of your
tendons so if you're going to get really
strong then you also need to give some
love to your tendons this is a really
good idea I made a whole video on tendon
strength so check that out if you're
interested
in terms of your performance there's
lots of reasons why having too much
muscle can be a bad thing for example if
you have too much muscle but not enough
cardio this is going to be a net
negative again you can be strong and you
can have good work capacity this is
certainly true look at someone like Ross
Edgeley or any crossfitter for that
matter however if you're not training
for this specifically then just having
lots of muscle is going to increase your
metabolic demands because a muscle is
metabolically demanding so someone who
doesn't do any cardio who's very thin
and not muscular is going to last longer
when it comes to long distance run
versus someone who's very muscular doing
the same thing but who also doesn't
train cardio you want to train your
cardio in a systemic manner that means
with things like running so you've got a
stronger heart you're pumping more blood
around your body but at the same time
you also want to make sure that you're
training local endurance because local
adaptations do occur in the muscle to
make them more or less endurance so for
example that might mean blood supply or
it might mean mitochondrial count or it
might even mean fast twitch and slow
twitch muscle fiber ratios either way
you need to make sure that if you have
that muscle you're able to supply light
otherwise you're going to be one of
these people who's super strong but gets
winded going up the stairs or who's
super strong but can't spy for more than
one minute and this is good for your
health in general because you need to
make sure that your heart is able to you
know keep up with the demands of your
body you will not get as strong as
quickly by doing cardio as well as
strength training potentially you're
gonna slow down a little bit your gains
in both areas but the overall benefits
far outweigh the negatives and in a
similar manner you also want to make
sure you're training explosively if
you're also building a lot of muscle
because building max strength is not the
same as rate of force development rate
of force development is how quickly you
can engage the maximum amount of force
possible from your muscles this is what
leads to plyometric performance and
Explosive Performance if you want to be
able to jump really high or punch really
fast if you have lots of muscle this
actually is going to slightly increase
the explosiveness to begin with because
you have a greater pool of strength to
draw upon however you will hit a point
of diminishing returns and there are
plenty of studies there's plenty of
evidence to show that you can increase
your explosive potential you can
increase fast twitch muscle fiber
density you can increase your ability
create those things some people think
that this isn't true and all you need is
strength training however that's not the
case otherwise athletes wouldn't do
things like box jumps at a certain point
getting heavier is going to mean you
become less explosive unless you still
train explosively unless you're still
ensuring that you can recruit those
muscle fibers quickly to overcome the
added weight so to begin with doing
heavy squats will make you jump higher
at a certain point you're going to stop
seeing those gains and then beyond that
you might even start to not jump as high
because you're just getting super heavy
and that's why you might want to scale
back and focus on something like bus
speed even focus on going through the
movement more explosively this way
you're going to gain more strength and
you're going to make sure you still have
the ability to tap into that strength as
well but these bulky muscles make it
hard to move fast I may have great power
but what good is it if I can't catch my
enemy it takes more than brute strength
to win a fight
so yeah guys those are a few ways in
which you can be too strong and those
are some solutions you can make sure
that you're building strength but in a
way that's good for you and that you can
actually employ whether you're playing
sports or just moving through life let
me know in the comments down below what
you think is this nonsense or can you be
too strong and if you're looking for a
training program that not only builds
max strength but also endurance Mobility
explosiveness Aesthetics even cognitive
performance then check out my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 I'll put a link to that in
the description down below that comes
with a massive 80 plus page ebook as
well as over two hours of instructional
video and it's designed to adapt to
anyone's situation and to build all
those things all at once with a single
training program in an upcoming video
I'm going to talk about how to combine
kettlebell training with powerlifting
and people really enjoyed that video on
athletic calisthenics so I might provide
an actual program for that for people to
follow as well so if you want to see
those things then hit the Subscribe and
Bell button either way thank you so much
for watching this one guys
[Music]
and bye for now